s'il vous plaît laissez nous enlever ce
voile depuis 40 ans et l'arrivée de
l'ayatollah khomeini les femmes
iraniennes ont l'obligation de porter le
voile
dès les premières heures de la
république islamique elles sortent dans
la rue pour protester
un combat qui ne s'arrêtera jamais
depuis trois jours les manifestations de
fin politique quotidienne à téhéran les
premières images nous parviennent ce
soir le rejet du tchador été l'un des
thèmes essentiels de ces défilés mais à
dire vrai pas le seul nous voulons être
libéré écrit cette femme de téhéran la
même année certaines iranienne
s'organise en toute clandestinité dans
les sous sols des facultés téhéran leur
objectif s'opposer à la nouvelle
constitution mise en place par les
religieux non parce qu'elle ne donne pas
les mêmes droits aux femmes qu'aux
hommes
non parce que la loi islamique relègue
la femme au foyer
non parce que le nouveau régime à créer
des tribunaux spéciaux pour les juger et
qu'elles peuvent être mariés de force
dès l'âge de 13 ans les années passent
et le statut de la femme ne change pas
elle est toujours considérée comme
inférieure à l'homme mais près de vingt
ans après la révolution le combat des
femmes est tenace elle tente toujours de
faire entendre leur voix
depuis 91 ce journal est une tribune
libre pour toutes les féministes et son
équipe ne cherche pas à faire une
nouvelle révolution non ces féministes
en tchador reste convaincu que la femme
peut s'émanciper dans le cadre stricte
de l'islam
aujourd'hui la femme iranienne même si
elle peut conduire étudier ou être
député n'a toujours pas le droit de
voyager sans l'accord de son mari ne
peut pas divorcer sans l'accord de son
mari
et toujours cette obligation de porter
le voile devenue le symbole de la
rébellion
comportons mon vol cette manière je veux
montrer que je suis libre de m'habiller
comme je veux moi ils m'ont emmené deux
fois au poste à cause de mon voile
depuis janvier 2018 la grogne populaire
monte en iran et encore une fois les
femmes sont en première ligne de la
mobilisation
aujourd'hui elle dispose d'une arme en
plus les réseaux sociaux où elle poste
des photos tête nue symbole de
libération
[Musique]